à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
pata plus je ne vous trompez pas notez
bien sur vos doigts world.com attention
il en manque un
[Musique]
les nouveaux locataires ils sont en
retard ça commence bien se sont fait
livrer leurs meubles des meubles st je
me demande la tête qu'ils ont c'est pas
ta peluche la peluche quel nom et puis
ils viennent en taxi en plus quatre
personnes dont un petit bonjour bonjour
je m'appelle pas de clous voici
mademoiselle pâte à coeur et patata
bonjour monsieur et pat asus seulement
partager j'avais compris avez-vous bon
caractère
or je pense ya bien pâteuse une bataille
où moi je vais pas bon caractère et j'ai
horreur du bruit autant vous prévenir
tout de suite
thomas la maison monsieur grotte de
niaux je m'appelle le boulou et fais toi
pas tabou
si je les parts de fournoux pas de dîner
voilà voilà
et ma coiffeuse il vient deux coups de
marteau mais elle est à toi
[Musique]
on attend
en
[Musique]
et comme
bon
non
à temps
[Musique]
et
on
non
[Musique]
souvenez vous de ce que je vous ai dit
je ne vais pas d'où il me faut bien
qu'on emmène à genoux sur ronchon vous
est imminent bon d'accord pour
aujourd'hui mais pas de bruit après ne
leur en a pas alors comment peut être
vivre sans heurts je vais vous prêter un
réveil n'a pas l'heur komax au vietnam
moi je n'ai même pas il m'a pas en
laisse sonnant mourront et tâchons de
faire moins de bruit
nous avons dû déménager à cause de ça
attention il va être maman
dépêchez vous
à la fin du mois
c'est ce matin votre réveil up
[Musique]
je crois que maintenant on peut y aller
du coup
tapie plafond
patricia ça
tapie
[Musique]
le
et
ponctué d'âge mon potager ce soit robin
et pour te faire plaisir il y aura un
grand plat de pâtes pata staff
qu'est ce que tu as dit aujourd'hui papa
chouette alors que le million
[Musique]
actions terminent ce qui lui a parlé
d'eux ne donnons aussi des clous tâter
suc
je n'ai pas possible vous savez ce que
j'ai vu sur la table de la cuisine
un paquet de pâtes c'est la huitième
fois que mon mangeant des pâtes cette
semaine site épouvantable ça fait
grossir bon aux grands maux les grands
remèdes
tu as des as tu un truc de pata truc
j'ai trouvé le truc
venez regarder le jardin de votre
silhouette
fait manger des pâtes en lui
l'île aux animaux
de la vie
oubliée la mort
attali pour garnir la table de votre
silhouette
[Musique]
des pantalons
la sambre à curieux n'y a rien qui crie
ça sent bon quand même
ne faut-il pas atteint coeur ce qu'est
ce qui t'arrive portée pour nous un
patin coeur ainsi vouloir maison on
regrette toi tu es trop faible
heureusement qu'il ya des pâtes pour le
dîner ta fortifie au messac attaqué aux
personnes assassinées pièce qui me
bombarde avec des pâtes alimentaires de
second choix
alors j'ai fait mon paquet de pâtes
comme intel fait sauter par la fenêtre
sans le vin on sera beaucoup de vin je
ne validerai bornier excuses et non
monsieur bouron ce n'est pas notre faute
on dit ça nous vous invitons à dîner
pour vous faire oublier ce petit malheur
lève pas les pattes a plu je viendrai je
vous ferai un gros plat de pâtes à peu
par monsieur bougon univers huit
messieurs bouffon dites moi la vérité
vous n'aimez pas les pattes
j'en ai horreur mais comment refuser le
gie gentille invitation à vous en faites
pas nous allons tout arranger vous et
moi notre cas monsieur bouvent elle est
en place les parts sont signalés sur la
droite
et voilà le plat préféré des pâtes en
plus des hauts murs ou chocolat des
merengues au chocolat c'était une
surprise pour monsieur bougon je voulais
lui montrer leur engagement le dîner des
ne soyez pas trop triste il reste un
grand plat de pâtes astros quel beau
soleil ce que les biens et demain je
serai tout bronzé à toi de jouer patate
à toi bien sûr vous vous amusez vous moi
je passe mon temps à faire la vaisselle
matin midi et soir qu'à raison c'est
injuste pata truc de pata truc j'ai
trouvé le truc que personne n'entre dans
la maison
[Musique]
chaque attaque fois qu'un travail entre
tous je veux tu vas tu déranges risques
sont pas pas une
[Musique]
18 ça fait dix-huit je retiens 2,16 et
pi 3 et 5 sur 12
ça fait ça fait que je me suis trompé
alors 10 puis 8
ça nous fait 18 5 et 8
ça tape ma main merci oui mais qu'est ce
que tu fais là toi tu m'espionne
retourne au jardin que je ne te
retrouves pas dans mes jambes quand je
reviendrai je ne mens pas nouveau
[Musique]
quelle sortie assez fermée à clef au
cloud non je vous ouvrirait que j'aurai
fini et par an ah c'est pas drôle et moi
je m'ennuie bourama atteint soir berdych
le soir bercy giba sans démocratie qui
foutent
j'ai barré bois j'ai pas encore bien
faire la vaisselle
oh là là je parle au public personne
trésor rugby situe notre passé et nous
allons tous à l'hôtel et nous trompe
l'oeil et la note
qu'est ce que tu as vu l'arrivée du dos
on
j'ai fini voir ces voies non après le
dîner
schumacher et voilà mais mais jette une
chope y est une caisse mais c'est une
machine à laver perfectionner à porter
les assiettes et les verres vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir dehors vds n
va de bart où elle belle histoire que
j'ai beau mouchoirs non mouchoirs s'il
vous plaît naturellement je ne faisais
attention à moi mon dire que les gens
disent prêts à offrir la lune
si le faut vraiment moche loi
quel merveilleux qu'est ce qui se passe
ici pâtasse prof tab élevé seule quelle
malchance mais pleure pas on en achètera
dos et ont passé trad autres vers
d'autres assiettes
ce n'est pas vous qui payez ça pour moi
mais si vous n'aimez pas assez les six
ans tu aimes tu les autres et assiettes
on voit tu me parles d'un scoop de
padoue grande vous si vous m'aimez
pouvait le mois comment décrocher - la
lune la lune la lune de là haut
oui mais c'est impossible
bah il le fait bien le bal dans mon
livre si vous m'aimez décrocher mois la
lune ne veux pas d'autre chose
zi l'allument
comme je joue bien la main
je suis sûr que papa parts doivent
verser quelques larmes
kata cloud tu as fait une tête pâte à
tarte pleurs j'en étais certaine c'est
parce que je joue trop bien du piano
mais non elle dit qu'on ne l'aiment pas
vraiment je vais me prouver le contraire
je sais pas ce qu'elle veut mais si mais
si tiens ma petite pâte à tarte choisi
ce que tu veux le veulent a eu alors là
la lune
[Musique]
à
le travail je suis mort de fatigue
as tu as dû te fais tu avec ce filet à
papillons jeu se rattrape la lune pour
papa part tu ne te fatigue pas j'en ai
une
viens
les
[Musique]
oh
m
pâte à tarte
bien vite nous avons attrapé la lune
[Musique]
tu voulais la lune
la voilà ou des bureaux au merveilleux
[Musique]
un bon droit à une élégance et parlons
gens de talent une non je te promets de
ne plus vous l'a demandé et a jugé trop
dangereux
ah bah tant mieux par contre
si je pouvais avoir une étoile
attacker pâte à tarte tatin zut
venez tous je vais vous montrer ma
dernière invention qu'est ce que c'est a
moulins à café un moulin à café cela
panneaux un aspirateur un aspirateur
maintenant il est ou stupides et c'est à
ses cheveux mais non c'est une caméra
projecteurs avec ça je vais vous filmez
et vous verrez ensuite comme à la
télévision
[Musique]
bravo papa pas à moi
qu'est ce que tu fais de la politique
mais monsieur bougon au collège
d'ailleurs je suis prêt
[Musique]
cette fois
des piges et
[Musique]
à
tu es tellement veilleuse merci patata
si tu veux je te donnerai une photo
dédicaces manquer ce que j'en ferais
attaque l'eau il faudra t-il mais
monsieur bongo
belle idée mais sans lui dire par
surprise
comment faire est ce que c'est que ce
bouquin une fois passe encore mais de
quoi c'est trop je faisais de la musique
ne te manque pas de moi pas tu ajoutes
bon ça faisait du bruit pour vous en
votre il avoue le choc
il a ce tout petit nom d'harry tard je
vais te donner la correction que tu
mérites dans un groupe 1 et pourquoi
parceque vous attend seulement s'il me
par la caméra de papattes loup film et
sac à papier
vous auriez pu prévenir j'aurais mis mes
médailles je suis bien comme ça
je peux sourire si vous voulez et quand
pourrais-je me voir sur un écran dès ce
soir
oh
il se vante s'il vous plaît un petit
problème technique
comment se demande le sommeil sans
pension n'est pas tout à fait au point
heureusement qu'on fait pas endormi
bravo bravo
nous avons beaucoup de talent moi
surtout encore merci pour ce film
superbe el maghili bonne nuit j'ai pas
ta plus
[Musique]
où
toi
oh
où
qu'est ce qui va faire une bonne petite
sieste date ajoute m
bon alors raconté mon histoire
d'accord il était qu'une fois pendant
possible si comme chaperon rouge la
grand-mare loin la parade c'est pour
vous
et l'histoire d'un petit solal n'avait
pas ta sud que l'epa tapis j'avais
confié à la garde d'un monsieur
bourgogne et patata quand vous fasse le
ménage pas drame seulement aux bras aux
jambes
messieurs vous savez pas d'autres
histoires je vais le calme et pour un
bon moment
on va jouer à cache cache pas qu'en
pensez vous qu'ils vous y connaît
je suis pas mal cachés ici mais les
mâles h au vieux bougon maria est pas
très pressé on se lassera pas de me
jouer un tour qu'est ce que c'est que ce
brouillon flotte
[Musique]
chercheur au fait c'est quoi pour vous
être mérité de moi je dire à papa
non non non non non non non nous avons
joué ensemble pendant ce temps changent
de contrôle non aux indiens aux indiens
et aux visages pâles fin moi la scène
mondiale
oui oui et moi le visage pâle bon alors
avec habillé en indien maintenant et
c'est bien tranquille plein en brabant
plume et puis l'aspect sale je suis prêt
et et peintures de guerre pour partir de
toits verts les indispensables le point
indien un peu de rouge ont pour devoir
c'est un maquillage dans thor
[Musique]
ajaccio en fait plus joyeux non-vie
d'art vivant je pense
partira ou un paquet pour les pâtes à
peluches
voila voila c'est certainement les
fruits confits que j'ai commandé
audincourt on sait qu'on a un paquet qui
marche
qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi tu criais le parquet annonce
j'attends et pas tu sais
ces bruits de moteurs silence les patins
peluche je fais la sieste mois
cossette encore pâte à tarte avec son
aspirateur ou pathak louer ces maudites
invention on dirait que cela se
rapproche
c'est peut-être une voiture ou un avion
[Musique]
je suis en danger ne bouge pas parce que
ce n'est pas renier pas courage je suis
là qu'est ce que c'est pas tout
ferreux c'est vraiment plus quoi faire
je fais clairement une clique de mercy
ce bruit continu
oui
qu'est ce qui se passe ici ce sont les
24 heures du bas
non de la kanaky
un paquet enragé
ah non j'ai jamais rien vu de pareil et
pourtant j'en ai vu
[Musique]
oh ne touchent pas packet data zut
pourquoi toujours pas pas eu le nez
creux d'un succès pour moi je suis ton
ce à quoi l'on de boîte de vitesses
je le veux commande la semaine d'or noir
d'époque de vitesse lors des riffs là
mais on ne sait plus quoi inventer
enfin la porte n est plus en donne c'est
affreux bruit de moteur au feu entre
femmes
je me demande si ça existe un grand
modèle
ce soir télévision très bon programme
je ne veux aucun bruit au ko l'attend
devant tu peux pas comprendre cette
attitude là mais pas oui si justement
sûrement pas couleurs cyan couleurs en
relief alors ce soir je m'invite je
serai chez vous invitera à vous en
faites des têtes
vous êtes malade on a bien monsieur
bougon qu'on avait la place jean moulin
rose oif pour le faire enlever la crue
il ajoute pour ce soir e
[Rires]
pat un truc de pata truc j'ai trouvé ce
truc mais la télévision en relief ça
n'existe pas ça existera ce soir à toi à
toi
batta zut
venez ses preuves la télévision l'a bien
de voir patent pas et voilà
bonsoir madame bonsoir mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur couleurs relief richard
monsieur bougon et sans apport de 6 en
relief ou pas il ya toujours des peines
[Musique]
bonsoir madame bonsoir mademoiselle
poussoir monsieur ce soir notre
programme commencera par une chanson
particulièrement dédiée à nos amis les
papas plus les patins peluche oui j'ai
vous oui oui on est connu ah ben c'est
gentil pour les autres téléspectateurs
moi j'ai poussé
[Musique]
keeneo cloud
amiri
oh
[Musique]
au près tout
oh
photo
oui c'est vrai pour
bon
[Musique]
moi j'ai la télévision depuis plus
longtemps goût et aucune présentatrice
n'a jamais encore dédié un programme je
peux parler louis est bien mal élevés 7e
speakerine elle est pas mal élevés elle
est très susceptible
c'est normal c'est une vedette une
vedette et quoi jamais entendu parler
devant la salle à papier en tout cas
elle est trop maquillée trop maquillée
viennent pas votre télévision en relief
c'est trop dangereux oh well m'a fait
mal c'est pas mèche suis très contente
de mes confitures vins confitures
[Musique]
défendue pâte à tarte
j'ai pris un petit pot vide pour y
mettre ma colle au déconfiture
v les cacher
sinon il n'y en aura plus ce soir je
vais t'aider personnes à moi la
confiture les oubliés maccoll ici je ne
pense à rien moi
[Musique]
oui tu auras une bonne surprise ce soir
aura tout quand tu es babines lequel
otazu tu te fais la tête
c'est en cause des confitures j'habite
en donner un peu vain bien fait pour toi
tu n'en veux pas tu as a bien tort lé
fameux qu'est ce que tu dis j'ai bien
envie encore que veux-tu je n'ai plus de
rouges à lèvres
veux tu que je te rapporte à l'illustré
pata zut zut
mais qu'est ce qui lie la matthieu boone
c'est bizarre d'habitude il ne boude
jamais mais tu as raison
pourvu qu'ils ne soient pas malades
colas l'année call instantanée de me
plaindre et au marchand de couleurs
ça sent la fraise
on en mangerait
ça cloue bien voire pas tu ajoutes les
bouts des pâtes à tarte et inquiète mais
ne boude pas il vous fait marchés n'ont
même pas voulu
notons qu'en tous préféré bon ça suffit
maintenant
la plaisanterie a assez duré une bonne
fessée aux maillys plaindra pour quelque
chose
il court bien vite pour un malade je ne
voudrais pas j'ai mangé de la colle n'a
qu'à se laver la bouche avec de l'eau
chaude
c'est la première fois que tu es tu au
lavo petite vanne news mansle et d'en
parler je parle je parle comme jésus
kotok pas car mon annonce que pâte à
tarte
mon gâteau avec tout un grand panneau
profiter
[Rires]
moi j'étais maintenant en attente quand
80 ans moi je sais et bottes mais moi
j'ai beaucoup mieux à lyon plutôt des
boîtes de vitesse toit ça n'existe pas
de profiter tout se passe bien
these mais inventer quelque chose
d'aussi important est aussi dangereux
bonjour monsieur bougon bonjour bonjour
vous avez l'air bien pressé je vais
m'entraîner outils avec mon fusil
assèche
[Musique]
pas mal pas mal du tout
et ça marche ça marche
le vol aa mais ça marche il va peut-être
essayer dehors
apparu que 59 ne sont pas partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en auvergne a pas d'arbres mais en
baiona en l'air n'y a pas d'arbres
meilleur bayonne à je ne sais pas juste
il va plus vite que moi
un drôle d'oiseau 40 ans que cherchait
jamais vu ça en campant tout me plaît si
l'on pensait pas prendre mon frein fusil
je cours le chercher lui ou pas le match
du siècle lui wa son voisin catastrophe
a sauvé cette attaque mais un seul
spectacle où revient ben je reviens plus
je suis là où ça je ne vois pas derrière
soi tous vos patins toujours la
prochaine fois je mettrai une armure jeu
sur un trop lourd pour voilà encore un
problème
attention voilà monsieur bouton
oui la bête le mot monstre est parti
vers pas ta vie
j'y cours ce sera lui ou moi le match du
siècle se sont enfin un fusil avec des
vraies balles je prends une décision
plus d'avions comme ça ce sera moins le
plus rapide
[Musique]
ou quel monde dans les magasins harrods
est morte de fatigue nachos pompe à fric
c'est pas possible tout le monde doit
faire ses courses en même temps
américain pour un petit bond à l'orangé
tout ça dans la cuisine
tiens pas tu as vite jeté apporté des
bonbons tout faire pour
[Musique]
moi
humana qu'est ce que tu as rien aulas
quoi tu as mangé tous les bonbons
pas tout à fait voilà me voit il en
reste un
maintenant tu as mal aux dents alors ne
te plains pas il a une dent qui doit
tomber at heart on ne peut pas laisser
comme ça il faut faire quelque chose
oui mais quoi nous avons tout essayé
[Musique]
bon niveau qu'ils à niveau pilule ne lui
en fait de l'effet il faut donc arraché
la dent malade je veux paris veut pas je
veux pas avec douceur dans la
décontraction et si je te l'enlève
tu pourras manger tous les bonbons que
tu voudras tous les bonbons fresques et
tu m'achètes un grand cercle de pâte de
fruit oui d'accord allait bien avec moi
je vais prendre mes petits instruments
[Musique]
non
elle protège prima
[Musique]
enfin
non
[Musique]
avant
tiens
qu'est ce qui se passe là dedans on
pleure on crie c'est la grande panique
monsieur vous vos gamins se battre au
petit je prends ça on met ainsi je
n'étais pas là très bien si tu préfères
te faire soigner par monsieur bougon
mais ne viens pas te plaindre après pas
tendu que l'histoire
vous ne pensez pas que le dentiste vous
tombez bien vous savez au régiment c'est
moi qui arrachait tout les dents dans
des manifs il
duffy
[Musique]
pas de crainte
pas de souffrance ses propres vite et
bien fait je vais ouvrir la porte d'un
geste sec et l'add on viendra tout seul
j'ai fait ça plus de 500 fois j'ai vu
voler des râteliers entier ah c'était le
bon temps
enfin nous attendrions pas très pas ta
vie tu alors on y va
allô allô le ciel dentiste
voilà mes potes
merci le baht monsieur bourgault
monsieur bougon j'ai un bon cigare
un merci bata zut
tu passes à mon journal du soir oui sa
suite c'est une catastrophe ma boîte de
poudre de riz évident
pourrais-tu demandé à tes chers petites
bottes ben oui le baht nous faudra une
boîte de poudre de riz le grand modèle
une paire de te paye les miennes sont
complètement rouillé il n'a pas de
teneur de ce qui se passe
ils sont gentils je me suis très bien
d'habitude les torrents pas maso
services partagés je n'ai plus de sucre
trop tard les pas de son parti dommage
j'ai un peu porté sur faty mois avec
toutes ses courses et ma poudre et le
bac ça fait plus de deux heures qu'elles
sont partis elles prennent vraiment du
bateau sur le manche est heureux
[Musique]
oui ma poule où sont les tenailles de
pâte à clous ou et à charge égale il est
arrivé à l'accident notes sont malades à
la pâte à choux tomates papa cloud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien fatigué elle ne veut pas de
finale un autre à le trou et un tacle ou
qu'est ce qu'on a fait un bon morceau de
cuir un peu de 6 une aiguille et ta
bosse à sauver paraissait en plateforme
l'époque tout ça mais recevra avant
d'enter boiteux chercher à peut-être
tabac aux basiques
il me faut du rouge à lèvres et du
parfum et okello pommes de terre si je
pouvais avoir un marteau et quelques
clous et boîtiers sont interposés ah non
ça ne va pas recommencer en au pied les
vagues ont démarré
je vous rends rendu berthonneau bat
recharge pour un adieu adieu le bac je
vous rattrapera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous allemands dans la mort qu'il faut
quelle chance
[Musique]
montoyer l'avait pourtant sorti tant pis
je vais en prendre un autre aux pièces
en colère
sac à papier on voit qu'ils sont pas là
pour tout le monde pas de taille
les chartes des messieurs bourgon
[Musique]
aux cheveux blonds votre âge quoi à mon
âge c'est ridicule
oh mais je vous assure que je comprends
pas du tout il vous ne comprenez pas moi
j'ai compris toi mon gars tu ne perd
rien pour attendre
[Musique]
on fait tout et oui mon c'est tout
m
elle
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
on m'a volé mon fait tout bien moi mon
sac à main mais je sais qu'ils elles vos
langues
viens avec moi
[Musique]
ton sac à main est ce qu'il ya eu la
guerre
alors vous avez recommencé à commencer
quoi monsieur bougon vous n'avez pas
honte honte de quoi c'est lui le
coupable
vous avez rencontré m'en fait pas
mention du golfe d'aqaba la plus cool
pour moi un nom non coté pour moi on
fait une tête
personne ne me crée sont pas tous sont
jamais de l'autre c'est parce que là bas
parce que t'es trop petit voilà on se
parlera un cousin pas ta belle qui
allait le match témoin il reçoit de la
france en avant
vous avez entendu attacker oui il faut
faire quelque chose
je n'aime pas quand pâtasse du tetris
bon sait-on jamais très longtemps
vas tu as dû te recevoir du courrier
eh bien il faut lui écrire mais à cuba
lui ai cru toi
pathak longs mois tout le monde nous y
mettrons dès ce soir et comme
enseigneront nous avec deux fourni et et
quelle adresse donnerons-nous qu'elle
celle de mes cousins c'était mes cousins
que je préviendrai ben ça va pas être
facile
cher petit ami inconnu
je te vois souvent de loin et je me
demande qu'est ce que je peux bien lui
demander quelles sont tes goûts
[Musique]
moi virgules j'aime beaucoup tout ce qui
concerne la mécanique le sport brin
surtout le football points et toi point
d'interrogation
voyons voyons moi j'habite une petite
maison dans un jardin avec des fleurs et
des légumes
moi je préfère les
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup la campagne
j'ai bien de la chance de ne pas revivre
en vidéo
[Musique]
et toi comment vis-tu j'espère que tu me
répondras très vite
t'as vu ta zut je viens de croiser le
facteur ya quatre lettres pour toi
atteindre mais c'est pas vrai je ne mens
jamais ils n'ont pas d'âge une attaque
nous attend pas fait mais vite monsieur
beaucoup n'ont rien rapporté le courrier
comme il va être content mon petit en
août
ça m'intéresse pas eh ben dis donc
j'espère que tu vas répondre à tous tes
nouveaux amis obama alors comment je ne
compte pas sa carte au ps on bat sur
trop haut pour moi j'en passe très mal